a major halo infinite bug could make you
lose your cosmetics a new halo trademark
has been filed and more
343 industries has advised players to
not use the xbox quick resume feature
for halo infinite's campaign because
doing so could cause players to lose
multiplayer content halo infinite's
campaign includes armor lockers that are
spread throughout the world and players
who find these can open them to obtain
cosmetics for multiplayer or that's how
it was supposed to work unfortunately
when players are offline or become
disconnected from the network the
cosmetics will not appear in multiplayer
using quick resume is known to boot
players from the network which is also
affecting the multiplayer mode prompting
players to have to close the game
entirely and reboot each time halo
community director brian gerard said 343
is aware of the issue and is working on
a fix he also promised that any
cosmetics that players unlock will
eventually show up in their multiplayer
inventory
now that the campaign and the
multiplayer have been released into the
wild that doesn't mean you'll stop
hearing about microsoft's big shooter as
a new trademark filing is indicating
more is already being planned microsoft
has filed a trademark for halo the
endless as well as the endless with few
details to help determine what it might
be referring to halo infinite has been
described by microsoft as its platform
for halo for the foreseeable future so
it's not out of the question to assume
this might be the name of the first
plane content expansion for the game
this would fit in with some references
to the endless within halo infinite the
endless are described as a race
contained on installation zero seven by
the four runners and most recently
encountered by the former banish leader
atriox during their meeting atrx
released the race once more with another
character named harbinger referencing
the race to master chief around the same
time given how broad a definition the
filing gives the name it could be that
halo the endless doesn't end up being a
part of halo infinite at all
this series has been expanded numerous
times across various types of media with
new books and even a brand new tv series
coming to paramount plus that we'll be
getting a closer look at during the game
awards
and speaking of the game awards while it
was released too late to be considered
for any other awards halo infinite has
still managed to earn itself at least
one trophy the game which officially
launched yesterday on december 8th has
won the players voice award anyone can
vote for what game they think deserves
an award in the game awards but the
decision is officially made by a select
committee the player's voice award is
the exception to that role giving fans
full reign over the winner after three
rounds of voting halo infinite has taken
the prize the game awards is scheduled
to start today december 9th at 4 30 p.m
pacific the show will hand out awards to
developers for making outstanding action
adventure games rpgs for supporting
their communities and then eventually
crowning a game of the year however
along with the slew of trophies being
given out today fans watching the show
will be able to catch a ton of game
announcements according to the events
hosts jeff keeley 40 to 50 games are
going to be at the show and a number of
new game announcements will be in the
double digits
we'll also be streaming the game awards
right here on our channel so be sure to
leave a like and subscribe so you don't
miss when we go live what new
announcements are you hoping to see and
which game do you think is taking home
game of the year let me know in the
comments and we'll see you tomorrow
you